-It's Christmas,
a time when friends and family
come together
to celebrate the season.
It's been a great night,
but it's getting late
and your guests
just aren't leaving.
-And that's when you realize
mistletoe isn't edible.
-Oh!
-Oh, that's a good one, Jimbo!
-You've given them
all the hints,
like commenting on the time...
-Can you guys believe
it's 11:00 p.m. already?
-I got nowhere to be.
[ Laughter ]
-...over-the-top yawning...
-Ughhhhh.
-I don't know.
-Ugh!
Ughh!!
-You've even tried standing up
and announcing, "Well, I guess
I should be going,
since it's so late.
Wait, I live here.
I'm not the one
who should be leaving."
-Well, I guess
I should be goin',
since it's so late.
Wait. I live here!
I'm not the one
who should be leaving.
-Oh, boy, someone had
a little too much alcohol.
Sit down, there, Cap'n.
Sit down.
-When all of those
still don't work,
it's time for the newest scent
from Yankee Candle's
Holiday Collection.
Introducing the "Get the [Bleep]
out of my house" candle.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's the uninviting, new
fragrance
that will let your guests know
it's time to get the [Bleep]
out of your house.
Simply light the candle,
and within minutes,
unwanted guests will be
a thing of the past.
-Oh, my God.
[ Sniffing ]
What's that smell?
-You mean the Christmas spirit?
-No, smells like hot garbage,
like someone
microwaving garbage.
Oh!
-I'm sorry.
I just remembered
I have a thing.
It's, um -- It's
my dog's ballet recital.
-Oh, fun.
We should do this again.
-Okay. [ Clears throat ]
-Now available
in a variety of fragrances,
including Old Shrimp,
Sweaty Crocs,
Hot Broccoli in a Ziplock Bag,
Egg Fart,
and New Jersey.
Any one of these are sure
to leave your guests
with a headache,
wondering, "Did I
put on deodorant?"
-Hey, I think
I'm gonna get going.
-No, you just got here
seven hours ago.
Stay.
-I'm just gonna
go run to the hospital.
-Whatever you think is best.
Yeah, okay.
Scatter. Scatter.
-This Christmas,
let your guests know
it's time to [Bleep] leave.
-[ Grunting ]
[ Cheers and applause ]